Benny FAL what may I ask you a question
yes may I ask you a question yeah this
is a question that The Internet's been
asking for a very long time and we don't
have an answer and it must come from you
sir were you in a movie with Donald
Trump called home alone too that is were
you the kitchen lady that is not me home
alone to I'm grateful for the chance to
put the record straight help Kevin
that's actually a female actress it's
not me it looks nothing like there's no
shame in it
Pi no not the pigon lady in Home Alone
too although I do go in Central Park a
lot and I can see the resemblance but
it's not me but thank you Benny I
appreciate it